[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to 10 best practices
in modern app development I'm Andre
Hammerly
I'm a developer relations manager here
at Google cloud and the team I manage is
actually the modern development advocacy
team which is why I'm up here on stage
today I'm lucky to be joined on stage by
Audrey Joseph from two Sigma can you
tell us a little bit about yourself and
a little bit about two Sigma hi uh MIT
Joseph
I'm a managing director and
it for Enterprise platform engineering
at two Sigma
I have been with them for six years and
have been part of two sigma's
application modernization and Cloud
adoption Journey
this slide it's a legal slide and it
says I won't be giving any investment
advice as part of this technical
presentation and legal aside I'm also
not the right person to give any
Financial advice
thank you
let me start with a brief introduction
of two Sigma
two Sigma is a diversified financial
services company that use systematic
approaches to run the business
we discover value in world's data
we utilize a large amount of data and
compute along with our own Financial
Insights
to generate strategies that run our
businesses across investment management
securities
Insurance real estate and more
we use vast computing power to onboard
large amount of data and test our
hypothesis at scale
at Peak we use more than 1.5 million
vcpus and 10 petabytes of RAM
our storage systems serve more than 300
petabytes of data every week
with that introduction let's get into
the topic of our session
so before we can talk about best
practices or practices for modern app
development let's all get on the same
page about what we think modern app
development even is so I just first of I
want to make it clear that we're not
just talking about development
development coding we're talking about
we're going to talk about the entire
software delivery life cycle today
next slide
so for the purposes of this talk in this
room today
we're going to say that modern app
development has the following
characteristics it's Cloud first and
container based in modern app
development the primary software
artifact is a container
modern app development also uses
automated repeatable processes for
things like testing validation builds
and monitoring
and modern app development usually but
not always breaks down applications into
composable and modular services this
allows water maximum flexibility when
you're building your applications and
putting your pieces together and it
allows different teams to work on
different pieces in parallel so why the
heck would you even do this next slide
The Accelerated state of devops report
actually has a lot of reasons to do this
but I'm going to only go into a couple
of them right now if you want to know
more you can talk to the Dora folks
downstairs
there are kind of two big categories of
benefits one is reduce friction for your
team
so modern practices can reduce the time
on a time it takes for you to get code
to production
they can also make it easier to deploy
frequency which also helps you get code
reduction faster
that is less friction for your employees
and it makes it easier for them to do
their jobs and innovate and add value
for your customers
another benefit that you'll see is
increased reliability
modern practices reduce the likelihood
that your changes cause problems and if
they do because you can deploy more
easily and you have less friction
getting to prod you can push the fix
faster that means your site is more your
side of your application or your service
is more reliable to the downstream
consumers
but
the next slide
modern app development is a journey no
one does it perfectly and not all these
practices fit every team some teams
looked at composable modular services
and they're like nope monoliths for us
all the way
cool if that's where you're at if a
specific practice doesn't speak to you
doesn't help your org that's great
we all do what we can and we're all
going to take baby steps you can't adopt
all these practices at once if you're
not using any of them choose something
that makes looks like it's going to work
for your team looks like it'll be
impactful and start there
so with that let's actually just give
you a quick overview of all of our best
practices uh uh first of all this list
is non-exhaustive these are 10 that we
felt were impactful but there might be
something that we left off the list that
you think is more impactful
also
we aren't actually ranking these in any
particular order we tried to kind of
make them flow well together but number
one isn't necessarily more important
than number 10. partly because like I
answered everything in software
development it depends it's going to
depend on a lot of factors which one of
these will be most impactful for your
team
so let's actually dive into the meat of
the talk now
all right the first one
before we discuss designing stateless
Services let me Define what a stateless
service is a stateless service is a
software component that does not retain
any information about its previous
requests
the key principles of Designing
stateless Services is to decouple them
from each other
so let's talk about some of the benefits
of stateless services
designing your application components as
stateless services will make it easier
to scale but because it does not retain
any local state
it improves resiliency because failures
can be addressed by bringing another
instance
also if one of the components fail it
may not impact the entire application
stateless Services makes it easier to
test and debug
because
your components are not coupled with
each other
it also enables rapid changes because
you can make a change to one component
and deploy that independently
now let's get into some of the best
practices for Designing stateless
Services one of the first steps for
implementing your application as
stateless Services is to divide them
into Loosely coupled components or
services with clearly defined interfaces
you should try to use
even driven architecture so for your
services to decouple them and even
through an architecture the services
communicate with each other by
exchanging events
unlike monolithic application backends
you should try to use independent data
stores for your services
you should also try to utilize
immutable backends so whether it's
serverless or containers for your
services so that it doesn't retain any
local state within the within your
infrastructure
so next best practice is a best practice
I'll talk about is designing for scale
when designing applications while we
give lot of importance to business
functionality we should also plan for
applications to scale
our applications are expected to provide
consistent user experience under load
without impacting the performance and
reliability our businesses grow our
applications experience
high demand at certain periods of time
and sometimes unexpectedly
additionally planning for scale also
helps with cost savings because you
don't have to over provision for the
peak demand
in case of two Sigma We Grew From
running our research on a small number
of bare metal machines in our office to
thousands of VMS running across
several kubernetes clusters in multiple
regions
[Music]
open source and cloud provider
Technologies and also implementing tools
where gaps existed
one such example is where we implemented
an open sourced a fair scheduler known
as cook
that schedules workloads across multiple
compute pools across kubernetes clusters
we gave a deep dive talk on Kirk in
2018.
now when you design your applications
for scale there are several
considerations the first one I want to
talk about is horizontal versus vertical
scaling in horizontal scaling you add
more instances of your application
whereas in vertical scaling you add more
resources such as CPU or memory to your
existing instances
the choice depends on your application
architecture if your application is
implemented as a stateless service and
CPU bound horizontal scaling may be a
good choice
when you want to scale your service
horizontally utilizing the auto scaling
capabilities of your orchestrator for
example if you're using kubernetes will
avoid over provisioning costs and manual
involvement
Auto scaling could be based on the CPU
usage or request count
you can leverage load balances to evenly
distribute your the requests across your
service instances
you may also want to utilize caching
strategies so that you reduce the load
on your databases or storage and reduce
latency and there are several caching
products available whether it's redis or
memcache D2 so that you can Implement
your own caching strategies
in we discuss asynchronous or even
driven communication patterns
um you could you could utilize that to
allow decoupling of your services and
and also that allows scaling the
components independently
as you design your application for scale
you should also implement
performance and load testing as part of
your CI Pipelines
earlier when we discussed the best
practices for stateless Services we
talked about utilizing immutable
infrastructure such as containers next
we will talk about why and how to
optimize your containers
so optimizing containers could be a 45
minute talk of itself and we don't have
the time so so I'll talk about some of
the very basic techniques in container
optimization today and I'm primarily
going to focus on reducing container
size
next slide
so why the heck would you optimize your
containers at all why would you worry
about how big they are
smaller containers have two big
advantages the first one is speed
smaller containers usually but not
always build faster
always start up faster
and smaller containers almost always
transport across the network faster the
speed of light is a constant
on the maintainability side your smaller
container is usually going to have fewer
dependencies that you need to track
make sure that our you're using the most
correct versions of and if there's less
of that maintenance work of your
dependencies less of that maintenance
work of components it's going to be
easier to keep that container patched
and up to date
so how the heck do you do this next
slide
um it sounds straightforward but having
been through this exercise with a number
of containers it can actually be a
little harder in practice
Step One is picking an appropriate base
image and I know some of you were like
obviously but this is actually hard a
lot of people start with a kind of big
bass image while they're doing their
proof of concept so they don't have to
pull a lot of extra dependencies in and
figure that out
that's awesome but once you're getting
ready to go to prod you need to go to a
smaller image that doesn't have anything
you're not using
um you can you can also experiment with
caching the space image sometimes to see
if that speeds up your build times
your small base image you need then you
need to add back your dependencies and
this is where I see a lot of teams
struggle you want to only add back the
dependencies you actually need in
production to your production container
which means your test dependencies your
Dev time dependencies those don't grow
in your production container some teams
have had success by building their
production container first and then
building a tester Dev container with
those extra dependencies on top of that
production container so that the base
images are very similar and ideally
you're reducing those works on my
machine problems
so that is the shortest version of the
basics of optimizing containers
now that you have the containers how the
heck do you build them and deploy them
let's talk about our next practice
all right infrastructure as code
infrastructure as code or I will refer
to as IEC is a practice of managing and
provisioning infrastructure using Code
open leveraging declarative languages
so in a declarative language you define
the target state that you want to
achieve for your infrastructure
all of the infrastructure resources
whether it's networks servers your
storage your databases
you will you will Define in a in code
and this code is utilized to provision
and manage the infrastructure
so there are a lot of benefits to using
IAC for your managing your
infrastructure I just want to refer to
some of them the first one is efficiency
automating your infrastructure
provisioning money and management
saves time and reduce human errors it
also encourages collaboration between
teams with modularity
next one is scalability
with IAC you can easily replicate your
environment whether it's for expanding
to a new geographic region or creating
more dust and main elements
when also defining infrastructure as
code improves the security by reducing
human error enabling change tracking and
security vulnerability detection using
tools automated tools or with manual
review whatever your approach is
the last one I want to discuss is
consistency with info infrastructure as
code
provides consistency by reducing drifts
between multiple environments that you
have
there are multiple steps for
implementing infrastructure as code the
first one is probably to choose the
right tool for you
most popular tools include terraform
ansible Chef puppet and and there are
probably other ones as well once you
once you choose the two the next step is
to Define your infrastructure in a
language supported by the tool
you also have to choose a source control
mechanism so that you have a version
tracking
for for the configuration files or the
the infrastructure that is you have
defined in code
git is a popular uh choice for Source
control for ISC
and then once you have defined
your infrastructure the next step is
figuring out how you automate the manage
the provisioning and management of it
this can be usually done by CI CD
Pipelines
once infrastructure is provisioned you
need to have monitoring to identify
issues and being able to address it
we'll discuss monitoring and
observability in general later in the
presentation
So within two Sigma we utilize terraform
for terraform as an infrastructure as
code tool to manage our Cloud
infrastructure
it has support for
all the major Cloud providers
resources and services
in case of gcp terraform Google cloud
provider is jointly developed by Google
and hesicorp and he's probably one of
the mature and well-supported providers
within gcp you can use cloud build to
apply the changes automatically to your
environment we will be discussing Cloud
build in more detail
later in the presentation
terraform also support githubs
so next we'll discuss the importance of
slight change Security in modern
applications
so one of the things that doing things
like infrastructure is code using
stateless Services brings in and some of
the practices we'll talk about later
brings in is the ability to have more
control of your supply chain
so let's look at the next slide
where I have given the absolute simplest
supply chain diagram ever this again is
a high level overview
and if you don't take anything else out
of this section of the talk I want you
to take the next picture
as your takeaway
your supply chain is vulnerable at every
step of the way that's the big thing you
can have vulnerabilities that come in
Via dependencies are some of the most
common ones we hear about things like
dependencies having a vulnerability or
potentially getting the wrong dependency
due to a typo but every step of the way
there is some sort of vulnerability that
you should be thinking about and
deciding how that works with your
company's security profiles and risk
tolerance
so what can you do about it well no
one's ever going to be able to say that
their thing is going to solve all of
your supply chain security problems and
if they do I'd like to talk to them but
there are a couple tools available to
you so let's look at the ones we have on
Google Cloud
first Cloud build we talked about this
last year but Cloud build could produce
social compliant build provenance so
that you can understand how your
artifacts were built and what sources
they came from
artifact registry allows you to store
those artifacts and language packages in
one place so all of your things are
together it's easier to track what's
going on where the artifacts are the
history of them Etc
I really like artifact analysis it's
awesome it scans your
art like about it is it will continually
update that vulnerability metadata for
30 days after the initial scan so if you
build something on Friday and a new
vulnerability or zero day comes out on
Monday it will update and let you know
if that artifact you built on Friday has
that new vulnerability in it I've seen
it do this for me multiple times and it
is Handy
and lastly binary authorization lets you
set rules this is that line between the
build and deploy state
that all of your deployments need to be
made certain requirements that you set
maybe all of your builds need to be
cryptographically signed before you
allow them to be deployed or maybe all
of them except that one container from
that one supplier that we trust but they
haven't gone around to adding their
signatures to their containers yet
you can set it up you can set it up
wherever you want and so it gives you
that information and make sure that the
stuff you're deploying is what you think
you're deploying
so all of this stuff plays together with
the next topic which is cloud native
release Pipelines
all the tools I just talked about use
cloud native release pipelines so for
this talk Cloud native release Pipeline
and Cloud native CI CD
are things that use the power of the
cloud to scale horizontally and allow
you to run multiple builds at the same
time or zero builds at the same time
they allow you to run all of your builds
in the same environment so that you can
see what's happening you can understand
that if you need to control that in some
way with security parameters or using
private pools you can
so let's look at the next slide we have
a bunch of tools we've already talked
about them a bunch so I'm not going to
go into a ton of detail here but Cloud
build is our Cloud native CI CD pipeline
it works with all the programming
languages that I've ever seen anyone try
I'm pretty sure I've seen someone throw
Fortran at it I know I've seen someone
throw Cobalt at it
and you can configure it in a lot of
different ways to meet your needs you
can do private pools and things like
that
Cloud deploy is the continuous
deployment solution that hangs out with
Cloud build I really like it because it
helps you visualize the state of your
system especially if you're doing a
complex multi-phase rollout it lets you
know what's done what's still in
progress at a glance it works with gke
Cloud run and anthos and recently in the
last six months or so we added support
for parallel deployments in multiple
targets so if you've looked at it last
year and you're like not quite there yet
I recommend you check it out again
but
I care enough about this particular
practice that you should be using
automated cloud-based CI CD pipelines
that I don't care use whatever works
just please do this uh so actually what
does two Sigma do here so depending on
the the team or the the business that we
have we have a couple of tools that we
use one of them is Jenkins we use also
GitHub actions in some other cases
yeah more examples of the whole it
depends solutions to best practices
all right so
when you start developing an application
teams have to make decisions on when
when to use manage services versus
implementing and operating one
themselves because something that you
might have implemented already or you
want to your engineers are interested in
implementing it so there are several
advantages for using managed Services
whether provided by Cloud providers or
SAS offerings that are available
so even though there are advantages
there are also some long-term
considerations that you have to take
into account
so we'll start with some of the
advantages
the managed service is free up your
engineering resources to focus on the
business problem
and not spend the time on probably a
building and operating a service that
has become commodity these days
cloud provider managed Services have
elastic scale well-defined SLA
availability and 24 7 support
while this can be implemented by your
like large engineering teams it requires
considerable effort
with reduced reduce engineering and
operational cost and the pay as you go
model that you have available in the
cloud
there is a good chance that you can
reduce the
total cost of ownership or TCO for your
application by utilizing managed
services
that said
while there are a lot of benefits there
are also some considerations
would using managed Services create
vendor lock-in for you for your
organization and how important that is
for your organization
can you utilize standard abstractions
while utilizing those services
within two Sigma we use several managed
services within our environment whether
it's actually behind our platform
abstractions as a backend
or directly particularly when they offer
standard abstractions
standard interfaces
so
for example and there are cloud services
that provide such standard interface so
for example DCS have an S3 or an XML API
right and databases like several of the
cloud provider databases offers postgres
as the standard interface right so
so that is one consideration like which
Services you want to use can you use
standard services or you have your own
platform abstractions that you consider
as generic and can be used widely
other other consideration is how much
customization you need
right
see in some cases you if you need like
high customization cloud provider
Services may not provide that
the last one I want to discuss here is
that this is not a complete list in any
way uh this is just some of the
considerations
um another one is cost itself you can
see the cost is on both sides and in
some cases the managed service cost may
be very high for the capability that
you're using from the managed service or
the value that you get out of that
managed service so that is another
consideration
next we will talk about observability
and this is probably very important for
all of you
so observability next slide is the thing
that we all know we need to do and a lot
of us put off until the very end and we
should probably not do that doing this
right really helps your team be more
efficient and be able to iterate a lot
faster so I'm going to go over this
pretty quickly let's talk about why the
heck you'd even want to do this
especially in a cloud native environment
or a modern modern development practice
environment first of all if you got a
bunch of systems a bunch of services
that you're composing you're doing a
microservices setup centralized logging
is key you need to be able to see
everything in one place you need to be
able to see how requests move through
the system related to that whole how
requests move through the system thing a
good tracing system open Telemetry is
one of them there are others that can
help you see how a user's request
started at your front end went through
three different back-end Services hit
the payment service hit the shipping
service and then trickle this all the
way back forward is really really good
when you get those weird bugs that only
show up in production so having a way to
set that up really really helps
and the final thing is you need to have
alerts and I am a big fan of making sure
your alerts are actionable I know we all
write non-actionable alerts but having
good alerting practices and good
monitoring practices set up really
really helps your ability to iterate
faster because you know about issues as
quickly as possible and you can fix them
it also means that if you're doing a
multi-stage deployment if something goes
wrong with that deployment you can stop
the deployment before it gets to
everyone
so we have some tools for this on Google
Cloud because of course we do next slide
the big one is called operation Suite
it's got all the things it's got logging
monitoring alerting
tracing profiling all the stuff is in
there I really like it it's a fantastic
thing if you're using our products
because you can just pull everything
into one place and then we've actually
demoed some really cool stuff yesterday
and I think again this morning in the
dev keynote showing how some of the duet
stuff works with our Cloud operation
Suite
uh however I don't know about you but I
have totally had to reboot servers from
the parking lot of the fast food chain
before because I was on call and the
pager went off well cell phone so if
you're a person like me who's been in
that situation may I politely recommend
the Google Cloud mobile app it lets you
see on your phone what's going on with
your clusters what's going on with your
application so if you too end up in the
parking lot of a fast food chain or
pulling into a lot Public Library
parking lot because you know they have
Wi-Fi you can you know hopefully not
have to do what I did and whip out the
laptop
uh two more left let's do the next one
all right so managing costs so even if
you don't adopt any of the other best
practices that we have discussed in the
session for some of you this may be the
most important one
so
also if you have been looking at the
these presentation or observing this
presentation we for all the other best
practices we also we had why and how for
this one we decided not to have it
because it's obvious
so Cloud offers a lot of flexibility
scale and ability to use resources right
wide variety of resources since the the
capacity or availability of that
resources is not limited as how in
on-prem data centers it is crucial to
manage your costs
proper cost management will help you to
guess get the most value out of your
Cloud investment
so we'll discuss some of the best
practices that could help you to manage
your costs effectively so the first one
is that you need to know who is actually
using the resource and who is incurring
the cars so you need to have the the
right cost attribution transparency and
monitoring
you can use whether it's Cloud projects
allocation tags and labels to attribute
the resource usage and costs across
projects departments or other accounting
units that you have in your organization
while Google console is a good tool to
to view costs and do some analysis you
could also export your billing data to
bigquery to do ad hoc analysis or some
complex Analytics
but there are also other vendor tools
available for you to do cost analysis
and visualization
one of the key thing to remember is that
cost cost management is not a one-time
exercise
it requires regular monitoring and
optimization
now let's talk about the some of the
cost optimization best practices based
on our experience
so we discussed about like earlier
throughout like in in multiple best
practices we talked about utilizing Auto
scaling capabilities
so this will this will helps to avoid
the over provisioning costs to manage to
meet the peak demand
so the next one is utilizing the right
machine types for your workloads whether
it's CPUs or gpus you should monitor the
utilization of those machines and
whether it's moved to different machine
type or right size them
foreign
can you use sport machines which are way
cheaper than the on-demand machines
and you should be able to use spot
machines as long as your application can
tolerate preemption or can continue from
a checkpointed state
so in two Sigma we implemented a tool
called Fast freeze which which can check
point and restore
application State running in containers
so this helps us in our case to use the
spot machines where possible fast freeze
is a open source tool and you can find
more information about it on open
source.2sigma.com
the next one is implementing life cycle
management for your resources
there are capabilities available within
Cloud providers to Define life cycle
management for your resources for
example you can Define lifecycle
management rules for your GCS buckets
right that will transition the objects
that are all to colder colder classes
within GCS line cycle management also
applies to other resources whether it's
computed machines or persistent disks
and other others
so the next one is about
minimizing or optimizing the data
transfer
if you are transferring data across
zones or regions or Cloud providers the
cost could increase as you scale and
utilize more data
the last one that I want to discuss is
committed usage discount so if your
resource usage is stable committed usage
discounts could be useful by by
committing to use certain resources for
a period of time and getting discount
from your cloud provider
so with that let's discuss cloud-based
development which is our last one
couple minutes left to step
substance so cloud-based development is
new to a lot of folks let's go to the
next slide I'm just going to say what it
is is it's not having your development
box you know a nice pretty tower under
your desk but instead having the machine
you do your development on sitting in a
cloud data center somewhere I've been
doing this for a while and I gotta say I
didn't like it at first I'm a fan now it
took a while to convince me and I'm into
it it's how I've been doing a lot of my
development work actually most all of my
development work for at least the last
year
so why would you even do this
um it's way faster to set up a Dev
environment I don't know about y'all
I've got a pile of dot files sitting on
the internet and source and every time I
go to set up a new Dev environment I
have to update them and even with those
it takes me a couple days to set up a
new machine
also if I hatch something if I need a
new version of say my name
and if I need to help someone else get
set up it takes even longer
with a container-based cloud-based
development environment I update the
container or pull a new image if I'm
just using a public container and I have
a new machine this is especially good if
you tend to break your development
environments you can just leave the
broken one over there and turn it off
and make a new one or if you need to
work on two or three projects
simultaneously say you're a consultant
you can have multiple different machines
that you use with the configurations
that you need
all of that leads to huge productivity
gains is faster I have my machine when I
need it and it also leads to reduced
cost I don't need to pay for a
development environment that's sitting
there not doing anything when I'm asleep
or when I'm eating or when I'm hanging
out with my family I only pay for it
when I use it and it's a pretty much
instant on when I need it so it doesn't
matter when I need it it's there for me
and it also tends to reduce works on my
machine problems if everyone's
standardized was on the same container
image so Google of course has a solution
for this next slide
Cloud workstations we've talked about it
a bunch over the last year
this is just a development environment
in the cloud you set up container images
you can set up ones for your team maybe
you have one for the back end people and
a really nice GPU based one
AI people or you know something similar
and they create instances as they need
them spin up spin down automatically you
can use it with vs code you can use it
with all your favorite jetbrains Ides
I use it I really like it it's really
really great for doing Development I've
even actually done serious development
and built containers while on an
airplane this way because all of that's
happening in the cloud all I got to do
is send the characters over the over the
wire and that was kind of magical for me
not used to being able to do container
builds over airplane Wi-Fi
so we've hit all of 10 and why don't you
tell us our key takeaways here all right
so let me quickly summarize what we have
discussed so far
so the applications that we build right
now require characteristics such as
resiliency portability scalability and
improved security to meet the business
goals
the modern application best practices
could help to meet these requirements we
discussed 10 of those best practices in
this session
but every company star may start the
application modernization Journey a
different point and with different best
practices if you're starting a new
application you could be using lot more
right a lot more than few like you may
be using lot
while if you have an existing monolithic
application you are and modernizing is
that you will be moving doing it in
iterative fashion starting with a couple
of them and then moving to taking that
Journey forward
so you have to evaluate the state of
your application and decide what is the
best path forward for you
foreign